here's what you've got let me make these
a little bit small so i can fit
everything across and a look consistent
ok now i ask you not to go on too much
further down to the information at the
bottom and i'll show you why there we go
ok so what have we got up here you've
got all of these bits of information and
we put that in and we can change that to
whatever we like ok there's a couple of
days where they didn't work any overtime
you can put a hyphen in there if you
like but doesn't matter ok now then
you've got an hourly rate down here now
I punched you in 13 point 6 because if i
put in 13 point 6 0 13 0 60 you press
ENTER and Excel says you're an idiot
because 13.6 our ears 13.6 however this
is meant to be money like what the
dollar sign that does ok so what you
want to do is you can either type in at
all site or this is a handy thing which
you'll see later if you go to up to you
to a Home tab right right here in the
middle there's a dollar sign ok and not
only will that put everything nicely for
you will format it and everything will
line up ok so if you hit that dollar
icon there you've even got different
options for currency that's kind of
Handy dollars will do for us right now
ok now when you get down to here right
of course you can go ahead you could say
eight plus eight plus a plus five plus
eight I think that's going to be 37 you
can add that up and you can punch in 37
ok but we're using a spreadsheet
spreadsheets can do this for us right so
i can say equals started formula it's
not an equation get it to do the
calculations for you and you could say
look I want to out this one plus this 1
plus this one I can keep going cono
right so watch what happens if I keep
going all the way to the end you can see
I've got the five cells tag I might even
just write down what you've got because
going to disappear in a second the five
cells and they're all labeled which is
kind of nice and they're all colored
just even fancier
okay so what you can see in for me it's
cell b5 it's equal to and now I've got
all these things here ok B 3 c d e and f
ok so if i hit enter 37 just like we
expected okay and now the great thing
about this is suppose you're like wait I
got something wrong ok I might go up top
here and say I actually lonely worked um
let's go that was got a Tuesday I only
worked six hours on that day okay when
you change that the normal hours are
going to adjust you don't have to go
back to that and say oh no wait I
changed something up above a bit of
change it down below because it's a
formula everything changes for you it
takes care of them does that make sense
ok now that's fine but this is well this
thing here this formula that we just
typed in right we can make it better
right at the moment it's just five days
so it didn't take us that long to click
across and get all five days right but
what if there were 50 days or 500 days
right you don't want to be cooking
forever so here's a better way to do it
delete all of those bits in the formula
there okay start the equals because I
want an equation to happen and what you
want is to add up all of those five
values or 50 days or 500 values right in
other words you want the sum of all of
those numbers okay so you can just say
hey Excel work out a sum for me right
now when you type that you might notice
that this sum this little menu appears
these are all functions there are all
kinds of things that as Excel recognizes
and you can just taught go for it and
it'll do some calculations there are
heaps of things that has access to ok so
to work out the summer of how of my
cells open up a bracket there right just
like if you remember when we were doing
tree if you're doing like sign of
something your calculator it opens up a
bracket right now with your mouse drag
across all of the cells you want to add
up
that make sense see what I did so what
it's now saying to us is instead of this
long formula I'm writing the sum of and
what does it got in there you see it's
got a start cell and n cell and this is
the range I want everything in between
does it make sense yeah okay now you
started a racket suppose we better close
it otherwise the computer throw a fit at
us right and then you press Enter BAM 35
just like we expected I might change
that Tuesday back to an eight so
everything matches because you didn't
change that Tuesday remember I changed
Tuesday and you didn't change you say
I'm fixed it now we're all got the same
data no satellite cool all right now
watch here's another good thing about
how to use a formula for this right see
this normal hours this refers to this
third row row number three okay what I
want to work out the overtime hours and
how they all add up to right that's just
the next row down so watch this take
that formula that cell copy it you'll
know you're copied it comes got the
answer on email right and then just
paste it one row down BAM exactly what
you expected because if you double click
on there look it's working out the sum
of the next row down which is the
overtime hours that's exactly what you
wanted okay okay so we've got two sums
so far so good yep nodding yes okay
right now I did it all pay I'll make
this a little bit bigger okay you guys
know how to do this you've got an hourly
rate you know how many hours you are
learning that right app whatever it was
right so how am I going to calculate how
much you actually earned over that week
you guys actually know how to do this
ready we did it yesterday right I start
an equation you tell me while I should
put in there what am I multiplying
together which two quantities by linear
how much I've earned over the week
yeah it's going to be that hourly rate
right so I've got that cell there and
I'm going to how'd I do multiplication
here which symbol do I DS the asterisk
which is above the eight right times and
I'm x because it's the normal hours i
multiplied by the total normal hours I
work which is that self-- yeah there you
go so the great thing about this is
suppose you're like your bosses like on
you've been working pretty hard for me
I'll give you a raise I'm very generous
so every hour i'll let you earn an extra
twenty cents right so if you change that
13.6 to 13.8 right everything adjusts
for you and it's all automatic right
this is why spreadsheets are useful do
have to recalculate anything just change
the one number that's adjusted alright
so comment 230 Quincy's how do i do
overtime pay I'll give you one for free
you're going to start with an equals
thank you for you've got a calculator
Tommy what am I x what you've got the
hourly rate right this time you're going
to multiply by the overtime hours right
but suppose suppose it's time and a half
that's pretty standard ok so I'm
actually not going to be earning this
amount every hour I'm going to be
earning this time and a half right
that's x time and a half right so it's
going to be fifty percent bigger does
that make sense so I'm going to take
that number and rather than presiento
i'll save x 1.5 there you go and that'll
make it time to half full there you go
multi bad for six hours work
yeah yes right just why everyone what's
overtime well assuming you can get there
all right so now I want to know how much
I've earned over the total week ok so
again we looked at how we can do this
say equals what am I going to stick into
this cell what formula well you reckon
spare d5 and adding them on oh right so
plus these things very good and there's
your total now by the way just suppose
it was Christmas season right and it's
all hectic and crazy right and in fact
they're like look I know it's really
really busy and you guys are working
really hard i'm going to give you better
than time and a half i'm going to give
you double time instead of time and a
half ok so what would I have to modify
in this situation to rectify that I'm
going to have to go back to sell which
one is it which cell am I gonna have to
adjust if i Justi 7th what's d7 doing
it's taking your normal total and your
overtime turtle and it's just adding
them so I don't want to muck around with
that one instead I should change easy d
six so i'll double click on that right
yeah I shouldn't have one and a half
that's what I'm adjusted right I'd make
it two okay and everything would adjust
to reflect that make sense